in this video I'll be introducing the
very last algebraic law of sets known as
de Morgan's law de Morgan's law was
founded by Augustus de Morgan and it
states that the complement of a union is
the intersection of the complements or
it says that the complement of the
intersection is a union of the
complements so we're gonna prove that
the complement of the union of a and B
is is in fact equal to the complement of
a intersected with the complement of B
so to do this we have to show that the
complement of a union B is a subset of a
complement intersection B complement and
vice-versa
so let's get started suppose that X is
an element of a union B complement if
that's the case then by definition X is
not an element of a union B and if X is
not an element of a TVV that is if X is
not an element of the region a union B
which is the red here then surely X is
not an element of a and X is not an
element of B and if that's a case then
by definition X is not an element of a
complement and X is not an element of B
complement therefore X is not an element
of a complement intersection B
complement so if we go to the other side
here we start by saying let's let's
suppose that X is an element of a
complement intersection B complement
then by definition X is an element of a
complement and X is element of B
complement by definition of the
complements X is not an element of a and
X is not an element of B and with the
same logic X is not an element of a
union B because X is not an element of
this region and X is not an element of
this region so surely it's not an
element of the two regions combined and
by definition of complements X as an
element of a union B complement